enfin la chaleur est de retour il ya les
asperges qui commence à peine à arriver
on attend avec impatience les fraises et
l'oeil est trop tard pour l'ail ou les
légumes racines qu ont accueilli
l'automne dernier ce qui fait que c'est
pas toujours celle de s'alimenter selon
la saison
un mois d'avril typique guiry froid
bouées et pourtant
je suis ému à chaque printemps c'est
sincère c'est vraiment une saison qui me
bouleverse parce qu'on voit tous revivre
le vert qui repousse partout amoureuse
de la terre et fervente défenseuse de
l'alimentation locale et de la
saisonnalité marie-eve savaria s'est
installée depuis peu avec sa famille à
waterville en estrie ça fait un an qu'on
est là et que jardin qu'on voit encore
en train de me familiariser avec mais on
découvre des gens extraordinaires avec
des valeurs justement d'autosuffisance
se réapproprier son alimentation
beaucoup de vivaces reviennent verdir le
terrain chaque année alors on a
ici ben c'est celle aux ayants que
j'appelle souvent mon citron la cale
parce que à partir du printemps le jeu
mais plus de citron dans mes enfants et
j'ai vraiment aimé c'est l'oseille as
cuisine super bien
manger local pendant les quatre saisons
au québec peut sembler qu'en gros défi
manger là quand ça commence par où on
habite un appartement c'est un intérêt
maison et une petite forêt pas loin j'ai
de lorthiois je pourrais vous montrez
moi j'étais leur sied
puis juste un matériau tout juste a
récolté 10 problèmes étaient six autres
couples soit cuisiner tel sera augmentée
l'aspergent au printemps la tomate l'été
la courge l'automne ou la pomme de terre
l'hiver des classiques mais chaque
saison nous en donne beaucoup plus
divers on va tout de suite allé voir les
épices ou les armes qu'on va avoir fait
sécher la sauge romarin le thym tandis
qu'au printemps baissé selon eux
d'erreurs dans ciboulette dans la
livèche des gens connaissent plus la
livèche mais ça goûte très mal sellerie
c'est frais c'est bon ça te refais butin
plein fait que c'est vraiment bon
[Applaudissements]
chez gilles pelletier à granby il
n'existe qu'une seule saison l'été et
cette année on allait là dessus on a le
con con on fait aussi des berges où on
allait tomates donc selon les cas de
bourse et en ce soir ne les tomates
cerises labo
ça ça prend combien
la petite graine dont le sommet au mois
de décembre
sont en fait un virage puis après sont
les amis en bacs au 1er février
fait que partie ce 1er février sera trop
tard tout un enjeu de recréer un
environnement propice aux légumes d'été
le problème n'est pas la chaleur mais la
lumière aujourd'hui toute la technologie
pourquoi la faire à moindre coût par
exemple les limiers à lille on à
l'électricité qui est une énergie verte
et celle de chauffage mais aujourd'hui
des systèmes de chauffage qui sont au
vert comme par exemple la biomasse ou
électriques
dans la famille des liliacées il y à
l'oignon un aliment qu'on peut consommer
toute l'année en une saisonnalité en
cuisine tout lois defferre déploie la
ciboulette en plein mois de janvier le
pam marche pas il ya des à nyon pour se
libère qui à l'automne en été puis au
printemps son trek et chaque saison à
son union
la famille des solanacées n'aime pas
l'hiver marie-eve attend avec impatience
les jours chauds pour se régaler mais on
aime c'est la tomate mais pour moi y'a
rien de mieux qu'une tomate qui sur le
plan en panne et était joint à manger un
mois ou deux par année puis je suis
satisfaite et je vais célébrer aussi son
et au québec ont un pays nordique où est
ce qu'il ya des ça pousse pas la pts et
la tomate tropicale ceux des fruits
séchés a besoin de beaucoup beaucoup de
soleil petit lait salama c'est aussi ça
fait au moins six ans que je peux
acheter une tomate
parce qu'elle a un grand potager la
cheffe fissionner qu'en cuisine aussi
avec les saisons notre corps aussi n'a
pas nécessairement besoin de toutes
sortes de trucs oui ok quelques
aubergines qu'on va manger parce qu'on
était capable de transformer notre corps
en plein janvier fébrile on n'a pas
besoin d'eux on a besoin de quelque
chose de réconfortant chaude évidemment
le truc si la congélation ou la mise en
pot oui on travaille un peu plus au
monde 2 octobre mais on travaille moins
pendant l'hiver pour préparer ses plaies
je n'ai pas besoin de manger de tomates
fraîches mais quand je vais manger la
première là ça va goûter comme le ciel
c'est un plaisir de retrouver des choses
c'est un plaisir de le monde qui est un
peu pour avoir le plaisir de le
retrouver
depuis les dernières décennies les gens
ont été habitués à manger frais toute
l'aisne si on offrirait repos au québec
la comète alani ses soutes et j'en
achèterais en importations pourquoi ne
pas le faire le calme et je pense que si
justement on attend si la patience les
deux justement de voir arriver du bon
maïs je veux du maïs
en balisant le s'attendre avec la petite
barque un brillant quand tu tes légumes
de conservation tout l'hiver le on est
comme enfin légumes de conservation
puisque souvent les betteraves commencer
par mer les carottes non plus trop
savoir les papillons germées tu rajoutes
pas l'hiver se rajoute la ciboulette
rajouter feuilles d'oseille elle est
belle de travail et à patates il ya
quelque chose qui fait que c'est bien
fait ou ici dans ce sens que tu fais pas
transition avec tes légumes racines
auxquelles tu vois que tu as fait ton
printemps est-ce que ça me dit que vous
mangez pas de de kiwis
mais j'ai été des années à arrêter les
bananes arrêté l'avocat met justement en
tout cas on est vraiment vite amende
pierre bel est prête à points puis a
attaqué le démange la nature est bien
faite de magie c'est toujours notre plus
beau guide alimentaire qu'on ne peut
elle va nous donner ce qu'on a besoin au
moment où en un coup on en a besoin
[Musique]